In what ways do you think Asian entertainers,...
...whether they are musicians or actors, actresses; how can they influence the Western market...
...which is clearly different from our own?
You know, it doesn't really matter where they come from.
The important thing is people should understand each other. Yeah.
If you had the chance to introduce Korean culture to people overseas,..
...which aspect would you like to introduce to them first?
Okay, that's a good question.
I love all Korean food you know, especially, do you know kimchi?
Kimchi's perfect, you know, it's amazing.
You should try it and I bet you're gonna like it. Yeah.
Do you like kimchi?
Yes, I do.
Yeah, it's my favorite.
What advice would you give to the young people who look up to you...
...and who want to be like you?
Just work hard.
You know, that's how I did it. That's the way to get there. Yeah.